what's up fool Podcast welcome to what
so full podcast we've been away for two
weeks
Louise a lot of things traveling with
recording two specials at the absorber
to a theater we went to Santa Cruz
we saw ghost Kobe Bryant passed away
with eight other people including his
daughter they got rid of Ari Shaffir
from the network we just saw his father
grab it in a trash can
man he just became public enemy number
one we want week it's crazy out there
bro yeah it got ugly bro I mean we
already show fear I mean I didn't know
how it works when they go after you two
they go after somebody you know yeah
they would have to meet two I got like a
50 emails don't you know this guy he's
your boy I got a couple messages going
so what's up with your boy but he's not
my boy last time we see noses all things
comedy is comedy a podcast first of all
two years ago it's pronounced bright
because they saw you on this show when
you were yeah it's a lot of connections
but they were going through comics pages
are going through his page and see who
follows anyway there's some so fat she
tagged me goes it's this guy your friend
I can't believe you're following him you
should all follow I will roll back to
her you know what I'll follow him and
then unfollow your stupid ass how about
that huh and then a fallen involving bag
do you got more followers who did Ari
Shaffir
you got like 2000 were followers on
people were people are trying to find
out information probably an ad or you
know just like well that little crowd of
people they want like a [ __ ] underdog
I [ __ ] with the world hero yeah
oh yeah please like a lot of edge boys
loving him none of the fools that live
right there where it lives underneath it
or people that dress like memes of
reality bro they were sweat and they sit
on a couch with Barbra Jean he didn't
[ __ ] Rama Doritos and then [ __ ]
scratching their eyes I know bro like
yeah but those fans that loved him and
you know what you draw the line I love
the Lakers yeah yeah yeah it's just a
lot to many people it was too soon bro
it was like well seconds that word Aflac
we were Aflac yeah man he got million
really even a joke talents are the best
thing about what he wrote
yeah bob was very clumsy how you put it
yeah lazy but I'll see did you know it
is it was like every career that could
comedian now or like we are like
reporter bro yeah I'm dying to be first
journalist Brown they're dying to be the
first guy to write a joke the first guy
just retweet a meme yeah doesn't having
all the information but that's where he
[ __ ] fell to that's like it wasn't
even funny
what was it even a joke you know
commentary yeah it was commentary saying
the news in a hate was very malicious
because it was just it was like making
fun of the fact very statement take on a
balloon or like a Babu didn't blow it
you gotta stick by your statements you
know and to delete them and there you go
hacked
yeah come on bro that's a fancy always
does that when people celebrities guy
but they do they were mitzi short I know
cuz you know you're gonna get yeah
to come after him right so he picks and
chooses bro he shows a black purse and
he [ __ ] up yeah black dude ancient
dude if you would have been a Mexican
doing that poet Mencia would have done
that would have killed him by being he
released that statement cause he was
just getting so many death threats and
all that they said they're gonna look
one of the comedy club in New York got a
bob through it yeah shoot up the cops
early g'bye perform I called in a bomb
threat I would be afraid though of the
drunk guys who sit at the bar after a
show that's what if I were Ari
all right that's what I'd be afraid of
you gotta leave he got it honey um yeah
just take it Peter
I guess Peter Louisa thank you so much
any other Laker fan man I was offended I
didn't even really know his comedy till
after I saw I heard what he said and
then I everybody told me I was talking
too much the more Indigo's know this
guy's been an [ __ ] to my nose for a
while well I remember a way back like
what was that 12 years ago 30 years ago
people are gonna like you know you know
dust them up a little bit cuz the racist
yeah yeah exactly taking them to the or
the day laborers and taking them to the
immigration office but then that was
like the heat was that real words out of
sketch oh that's rude a cuz I remember a
Marilyn Martinez talking [ __ ] so his
stuff is that stage I thought it was
stage it was like the contemporary a
wannabe ND costs a showering Tom Green
exactly exactly the in utter shock that
was his uh his like little name right
the amazing race's amazing amazing rayon
high school I was popular and we're like
that's funny but then it back then
valence wanna you know even if you were
Mexican
[ __ ] that still play I was like dude
imagine how many emails Joe Rogan got
yeah I do
he's been excited about the whole bar
dude bro I said only that cuz he works
for a company bro like UFC that's a
company yeah and I pretty sure if if he
will make that statement here we got
fire yes like Dawg career done yeah but
I'm pretty sure like some data white buf
to hit him up a name I think I are your
friend yeah exactly
not anymore but homeboy say that's right
that he [ __ ] up and homeboy [ __ ] up
well he finally said it cuz he's been
quiet about the whole thing
irony to see all the bad stuff from
people who actually do this Omar said he
took all the heat from like a lot of
people a lot of people when I talk you
know all he's one of Joe Rogan white
mediocre comedians you see that Godfrey
video yeah so you ain't even that funny
bro he just picked on the wrong guy to
say the wrong and I'm older I mean throw
Kobe Bryant as it was an optional was an
exceptional basketball player but to
these younger kids what he's saying what
he said was equally as bad and what
Malcolm X said that about John F Kennedy
a path through the way yeah oh good you
know you we love you Malcolm
but that is why you say that ball J of
Kennedy at that way come on is here the
roosters have come chicken chicken home
to Rome and once again made it made that
item damn I was thinking about it once
in a real I'm like a comedian made that
reference to it's the same thing bro
like something you don't charge it oh
wait oh wait a while man and make it
funny make it fun has to have some sort
of humor there was just a joke which was
hacky I tell you no but it was funny I'm
all about freedom of speech man but that
was just commentary but you gonna give
the repercussions Brady allowed if you
have fire and if you're not firing a
movie theater just to get a laugh
and then people get trampled you're
gonna go to jail for that yes yours and
then putting salt on the woman by making
a video out of it that was Yi right
after DJ Quik made a video of him
driving around so I'm looking for uh Ari
Shaffir he's driving around like your
price your Philip on like you like it
somewhere else
DJ kuzmina video of him filming on the
link in the south he's not over there Oh
13 min opposed I'm coming to look for
you high level people comment below see
any facebook el amigo que sus carros de
contas
- amigo yeah he's bad from buying a
basketball bro he's not allowed on
Figueroa ah that's a nice almost Angeles
right saying like you're now a comic
well I prefer warmer now a comic now not
knowing Los Angeles yeah you got you got
a bolo Santa to be part of Los Angeles
[ __ ] yeah like I I know how much
love that fool got he started here bro
he came here no 17 who Oh Kobe Kobe
Bryant I didn't hurry otherwise yeah
Danny Trejo or bro yeah dude okay so
maybe once he makes me any jokes about
Fernando later on yeah yeah you can't
even defend that yeah just my daughter
who lives in Sweden she heard about Kobe
right back in a way and she said it was
all over the [ __ ]
everywhere that's to really happen boom
boom boom yeah Mexico City Tim was a big
deal you were in Mexico City no but I
had my comedian friends tweeting in the
video from all over the world have been
to the Staples Center behind its back
yeah there are actually taken out there
packing it all up and giving it to
Vanessa because she wants it they're
gonna you're gonna kinda like it they
just announced it like two days ago
that's what they're doing she's gonna
fight a lot of basketballs that people
left there they're like truckloads of it
there's sombrero somebody actually was
playing purple and gold conscious
biodegradable stuff and put it in the
planters around Staples Center in all
the planting all the flowers and stuff
and then all the physical things they're
giving to her and then they're gonna
like catalog him and I guess hold on to
them because there was some other
tragedy that happened the Taylor Swift
was at the Taylor Swift the bombing at
her show or ariana grande show whatever
yeah that bombing they started that's
what they did they collected all that
stuff blast
Ayana bro that full blast that fool had
a gate he had the sacramento punch
language with me Gabriel s in harmonica
CEO mr tamori no enough [ __ ] um the
Lakers were having problems
I think Shaq and Kobe were like not
fighting there was like three clicks and
like in the [ __ ] um in the team there
was a Shaquille O'Neal click Kobe Bryant
leg which is only him and two other
fools and then the Rick Fox click which
is the old schools the bridge but yeah
they were not getting along so [ __ ]
um the coach so Jackson said okay after
we're gonna have after practice we're
all gonna have dinner together like
little boys then they all had dinner
together dog all the Lakers steaks there
and then after that we're gonna watch a
comedy show and they just show the
random comedy show and it was our
[ __ ] comedy show no show we found out
the punchline
Sacramento punchline they were playing
Sacramento Kings and they told us
in the back and come in late and they
all came in they were there their desk
or table was by the green room so [ __ ]
we call it blasts oh yeah la Hilda
Biscayne Lopez cousin he was already
coming to the game well I'm sorry coming
to the show so we called him up as a man
Kobe Bryant okay should kill him Neal
Rick Fox are the Robert Horry all these
who's gonna be here that fool would you
go buy a [ __ ] basketball I think I
read that dude's I had pictures and
showed up no I had that [ __ ] you
basketball sign he ought to my son he
ain't born here but just looking at what
I did bro my lover Kobe Bryant Spock to
us for a little while and he said that
him and his wife might show up and check
out our Latino tonight he never showed
up though they said now the same weekend
that Rodrigo and Benny man I showed up
starving bro from our dribble dribble
run liquor make you guys put a black guy
on the show yeah yeah I remember
we have black guy in the show with that
one made you or the club thought maybe
it's a good idea how they pick this guy
Michael jr. that was Kobe's favorite
comedian Michael Richard tell you the
story so the Lakers was there man and
then after that man did you get
autographs from the Lakers you sure I
had a photo bro but I lost it and it was
a photo that I'm Gabriel I supposed to
love Kevin Kobe Bryant I had the
pleasure of having the Lakers at my show
[ __ ] we all had the place
however people like you know when you
like when you were there with a bunch of
people but then they'd only put the
photo and make it exclusive like it was
just that yeah that wasn't from a staple
when a hot and fluffy 2005 2005 Kobe
tattoos again you shared with that OC
artist you shared that one it was like
oh my god alright that's a tool in a
garage sitting at our desk ouch bro man
and like somebody just drew spider-man
first I see better happy come on I told
her like somebody drew spider-man
further and decided to put the web with
a costume and they say you got a picture
of a [ __ ] Toby Higgs some are just
foul dude and they're [ __ ] a walls
with those things yeah that's like
cousins hooking it up with Tati's right
there man you know that's like that I've
seen even better tattoos in garage bro I
got my face with my [ __ ] 3 dots right
that bro my friend I ride old eNOS NATO
American guy you're part of the young
drunks and that [ __ ] a real tattoo of
a native chain with big boobs and I told
a guy night out I'll give you one I'll
just grab my hand I'm cool tattoos look
awesome up but they are freaking painful
bro the same guy Roger brought that tool
that a pimple busted
but I'm sure like that tattoo was made
with guitar string right that thick I
don't know bro that we all have a bow I
don't know like it look like a big pin
the white part yeah he was a crackhead
and you're tattooing everybody for
whatever money you have bro yeah ten
dollars to see what I could do you say
huh Cheech was going yeah I'm gonna draw
a gun and then we're gonna give a black
eye that was the one happened to my
friend bro throwing up he popped that
pimp on her eyeball so now her I know
they got shot tonight huh no her I don't
have a Native American who lives in a
trailer park brawl got a boyfriend
the Comanches Peter man we throw from
San Diego brother I was born and raised
and say well actually min Peters way I
was actually born in Tijuana California
I knew it right California 44 blocks on
the border ice and then thanks to
Reaganomics when they started giving out
green cards two extra days sitting up
back in 1980 exactly 81 82 my dad came
home with green cards for everybody like
that dude oh man and then we move like
typical Mejicanos with San Ysidro like
four plots we live four blocks south of
the border and then we move four blocks
north of the border to San Ysidro
California bro my cousin there started
zero who use their their passports to
get in Jimmy Carter with her giving our
[ __ ] even give up peanut smart not do
you Ronald Reagan open those doors and
Ronald Reagan gave me the Ambu they had
a that's right on my dad
there's people from those times who
still vote Republican because yeah yeah
they're like [ __ ] you we got here
legally that's right dude right that's
why some just I get together with my
friends I mean the ones that were not
born in this country and we all start
drinking and smoking and they all start
sharing their stories about how that we
walk for 17 days we drove our best the
Isla Vista is the the train you know
what I'm saying and I got like well no I
just kind of came here with a [ __ ]
diner bro yeah I do translate the news
there was no test by the television for
your mom today I remember 52 and 34 yeah
I was born dogs with only channels and
then 22 sure all the Mexican
black-and-white movies well it could
mean a pretty one here like Colonia
LeBaron yeah bro okay the 13 were your
parents from yeah right there bro alone
addressing bro awesome on but deliver
that blow or we used to live on a street
that went all the way down to a city it
was a big-ass [ __ ] here bro we still
live my cousin used to live near to a
pilot error where they make ice cream
with dirty as water part of the bro yeah
did you ever go to the temple on the on
the cathedrals actually like I ever say
it was the only [ __ ] Church the whole
community I've been there back in the
day Colonia Tracy bro where he's robbed
or the battery were hiding or the what
are the bathroom we're all cyanide put
the Train see ya pause alright to take a
bath you the bath it was brought in
every morning we had all the immigrants
show up in my grandma's house I believe
taco something like a lamb on Garraway
me aside what a lot man get I really
like that because we live for four
blocks at the border we're your parents
from originally from TJ my dad is from
TJ my mom is a Culiacan Oh
oh cool yeah country no law and she only
ended up in TJ because remember when the
government chuckin you broke us in a
local as peaches Malaya Laura's huh and
they [ __ ] kicked all the drug dealers
out and they all [ __ ] move - [ __ ]
Pequannock out on ya man let's play that
people honestly spread that shitty
networking Doug right but with green
cards and everything that's why I didn't
I rich liberal now San Ysidro my cousin
over there - where I live in San Ysidro
four blocks from the fort they got shut
up by a by a commotion madam it was a
part by Willow elementary there was a
[ __ ] Park I forget it
San Ysidro poor no no no no Sun field
Larson feels here mama yeah these
McDonald's they're starting over my
cousin lived and it was shut up by a
happy another person for a suti yeah
everybody yeah Vietnam vet yeah deer and
then when that happen that was happening
like in 84 hey como peachy la gente como
se mentiroso like when that [ __ ] do you
know what happened no no no I don't know
about he told me about it because we
went to that McDonald's to go eat there
the one that's still there right now
and it was quoting well they don't exist
anymore
yeah but no bra was there when it
happened you were inside no no no was
your on the playground I wasn't there
when it happened bro I always I was
sexually driving my bicycle like like
all the Mexican says do you know what we
were we were gonna go but you know but I
was actually there with my friends we
were just [ __ ] around in the area and
I saw when the SWAT short I got late
you're lying down no bro I got there
late I got there one the SWAT showed up
and I remember being they already had
like lined up the whole area and I was
there with my friends kickin it because
bullets were [ __ ] flying now this is
what the was [ __ ] on the freeway damn
m16 bro yeah what race war he shot so
much he was a Vietnam vet he was a white
guy
people in Mexico yeah it was a white guy
always had always fatale the mexicanos
aji zeppeli allah he always get into
fights because he lived a normal racist
- yeah well i will go hand in hand
yeah and he showed up bro and he order
his burgers and he opens up his pair
consonant he opened his [ __ ] quote
and he was well armed and he [ __ ]
started shooting [ __ ] everybody kids
running outside my 24 people in SWAT
team garden yeah the SWAT team got him
bro I remember I was there when the SWAT
when the SWAT showed up and pretty much
man that you know the [ __ ] widows
don't [ __ ] around
I don't play and then I I couldn't hear
what was going on but I draw and then
the guy goes hey you [ __ ] you go up
there and a better vantage point he went
up there and it was a cup of a bank and
a bank was across the street from the
McDonald's and all I sighs it I hold me
running up the [ __ ] building and he
went up and you can see him from the
bank but all he had his hat he put his
rifle down he set up his rifle he put
out a walkie-talkie next to him he honed
his hat he [ __ ] lined up the shot and
he just [ __ ] went like I'm ready like
I couldn't hear what he was language any
[ __ ] like he got the orders to shoot
him he killed him he nailed them one
bullet in the [ __ ] head and the
bullet went through a fake wall and two
glass windows Wow beautiful
yeah right good that's art block that
guy bro that's right bro what you heard
it was doing the us how to shoot [ __ ]
Olympics you know they don't do that
[Laughter]
and then they put their arms down
that's a [ __ ] move yeah you see the cop
in the car I was surprised a shot Oh bro
I mean white guys don't get shot near
get arrested again a lot of them got
like [ __ ] though for like Scarface
anymore bro best carjacking bro with
lethal weapon but Gary Busey crowd that
lady or then do it [ __ ] with a face
sorry about drive your [ __ ] driving
you know a lot of [ __ ] moves dude with
that [ __ ] yeah
what are you gonna hurt innocent people
yeah but no matter what their problems
he just had it well deed post-webinar
sad UCSD man but it goes on white men
are sad right now bro why's that because
there's a lot of good
keep black guys Latinos no and then
there this is a Super Bowl and they see
two hot latina shaking their booties oh
there's one is that Kate Perry with no
ass yeah that's fun for real bro like a
real man when when people say equal
rights some white men thing is no rights
for them right like Equal Rights a white
man things they're gonna have less
rights when or even always have more
rights but they don't think that way you
know right so they get sad the other
people who don't live in the city but
people who live like in the boonies yeah
like in a farm would have no content
less people bad people it lives through
like Fox News or Lou Dobbs but also they
were overall they were like overalls all
day bro with [ __ ] sandals same effect
no underwear it's sad you know like like
it's like so white men can handle being
black for for one day April now do they
get mad no they they get mad you get
[ __ ] shot the vision of what they
thought the country was is not there
anymore
I know I did won't you that came from
their parents you you tell like have you
been - oh like little little like
Alabama or Tennessee little backward-ass
wrong so happy ass how over there bro
you know but Billy axe is like traveling
back in time bro these guys haven't let
go that all that oh that those goats
that's what like with Sam Wilson in this
special van they brought syphilis that's
why the Europeans give me a [ __ ] go
come on learn about history when that
guy [ __ ] book rule the books are
gonna save you
we're professor John was two names and
one to this Salvadorian look at my focus
there daddy
Missy is cousin Central American head
for real brothers there's Mexican men
who feel sad too or there's Mexican men
who've been here forever bro and they
see a paisa and they can't see them as
the same person that they have are any
more like a they see a pilot here a new
immigrant and they a Mexican man being
forever and they see like I'm a new
Mexican guys show up they see what the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] is [ __ ] up for us yeah
yeah did my these kind of culture
Cardinals by the way but I think the
media does that talk every embrace [ __ ]
with your head my bro like like the best
the best part and you read French
dollars book yeah babies giving Kramer a
ride home Richard whatever name the real
quick Michael Michael Richard yeah you
go any Indian a beach Kramer goes turn
off the radio
anyone fresh story was why I don't want
to get influenced every either one I
didn't want to hear not no opinions of
what anybody has to say and that's the
way he lived his life
it's all gibberish bro thought Jim but
meanwhile he let you know there were the
Laugh Factory stuck up for that fool you
want our let her in and then they showed
a picture of him and everybody started
laughing flop it's not 40 same thing is
the Jewish theater you know bro
it wasn't even jokes he wasn't like we
used to call it he lost it like he
started bringing a home and the laugh
actually looks [ __ ] up [ __ ] like don't
throw you in a pitchfork and yeah to
YouTube and laughs I hear they sold that
video right yeah man they sold PMZ that
started
the TMZ was next door watching waiting
for Paris Hilton and then somebody heard
Cramer you allowed the n-word and I said
come on in come on in you need to take
it yeah that's what started yeah like
say like TMZ that and then also
Britney's bald Britney Spears bro that's
what's our team's easy like yeah I don't
understand what kind of pressure he was
that me I mean I have some pretty
[ __ ] rough sets man but yeah enough
people
i'ma tell you right now people it's a
public announcement for every Latino
comedian out there enough was a
coronavirus jokes haha okay you dream
Odell okay the next guy said he just a
cottage someone else a daydream
Budweiser is the same [ __ ] job let it
go now let boy your arrest right where
to read about this money my girlfriend
has the table now Larry's my girlfriend
to you or a Corolla virus you know why
they call Coronas why the corona virus
why cuz there's got spikes like a crown
I don't know why they made it in Spanish
though why not the crown the crown vibe
the King virus will make crown [ __ ]
dragon alright and it was turned because
people were eating bats bats roll it's a
whole bag they put it on right right
right or do you think is man-made dude
you know patient zero by the Chinese for
me but [ __ ] it's like everything every
presidency has their own virus bro okay
Obama had the swine flu though man the
Agra falls virus
swine flu swine flu was a bomb that's
the court right shake your flats [ __ ]
up my cow disease President Bush yeah
the swine was Obama the swine and swine
flu this way Hobart and now that was a
bird president of the bird flu swine flu
is from Mexico Mexico it was like a poor
keep him up somebody bad poor it yeah
yeah then a mad cow disease with all the
cows eating cows cause eating cows yeah
damn carnivorous cows huh everybody
everybody has a role little scaredy
every time every time like it's time for
get the flu somebody dies yeah do people
die from the flu every year hundreds of
thousands of people the regular flats
right babies in like really old people
[Laughter]
[ __ ] the babies aborted the embryos
the placenta the [ __ ] be aborted
babies for better hell aborted babies
[ __ ] videos of it bro aborted me all
right baby I'm not watching any Bravo's
park-like abortions like the fetuses and
they're making soup out of that [ __ ] you
know what the [ __ ] come okay what the
[ __ ] we
little casket heart like that guy in a
little casket horn we're divas anyway
nice
fool over here away bro dog right now
well do you not noticed it's not as like
it's bad like we don't eat rats and
start a dipper weed process me bro we're
killing each other for the [ __ ]
popeyes chicken ramen having [ __ ]
mind I'm gonna need a little change yes
I used to eat not anymore
no man no bro one of my first jobs I
used to work at our it was a meatpacking
company farmer John
no not farmer John's but it was a me
tell you I don't eat the hot dog because
they killed the cat nice a dose used to
come in they used to cut all the meat
right and they used to make their cuts
and [ __ ] like this and then the bell
will ring and everybody would leave and
it was my job to take out the middle
because it wasn't like but the pet is
the way people used to stand on they
were made out of metal with holes in
them and you used to take out the
[ __ ] metal things but the [ __ ]
matter
yeah
today the middle they're already made
out of my flesh I don't know man all
those bacteria job wants to take it out
and scrape like that even without notice
bro Chris boundary [ __ ] nasty as it
fails if you were to cook vegetables I'm
sorry it's good bro but that's what I'm
telling you
I was my first date I told my boss that
what are we gonna take you home to
Moscow so you became Muslim right you
got that good job the guy told you put
it in those yellow petals sorry with a
scrape bro what happened we would scrape
all the shake on a level way and all the
[ __ ] mud and all the nails and all
the bees all the waste yeah bro and the
guy goes and we're gonna toss it we
couldn't throw it him on the garbage he
goes nah bro you put them in those
containers and I said what do you do
with those do that we make those hotdogs
yeah but they clean them filling you
with some water and then oh yeah oh it's
no mommies we nail the [ __ ] nail hot
dogs it's not a snout it's the loose
it's the waist grinder there's a big
stoner grinding that movie with Dan
Aykroyd and John Candy and there's a
little greater door the raccoons are
talking instead you like hard to know
they took this Oh Liam
[ __ ] it's nuts no it's all the waste
because I know in Mexico people go uh
they go like camping something they eat
rats and they eat like the little
animals those are from the forest you
can eat those are not like City rats and
chicken I mean or the true rate that you
can you can I mean over here you'd have
a lead us if you have you can eat
well you can need any animal his blood
[Laughter]
apiece go yeah well you and I were in
Denver and knows a guy who had all kinds
of sausages bro
alligator so I put it to the alligator
sauce they were made out of [ __ ] - uh no
can't do so I think there's probably
made cleaner it's all that meat that
they don't use on the [ __ ] animal if
you can get prime sausages in priming
you know they use a little bit of the
fabric they use more of the meat not
like the snouts and the ligamentum
that's funny I saw a movie bro it's
called the grand budapest hotel and it's
old ass dude like the maitre d and he's
telling this guy oh yeah I had sex with
her
she goes she's 84 years old if I ever
had older you don't understand it once
you get older man you move away from the
prime cuts and you go for the meats you
know the dark beets there you can eat
anything as long as you control its diet
now you put lemon bro you know you can
eat this nails
you know it's French eat escargot which
is but there's a certain type of snail
because you can die if you eat those I
sought out some ways to die so many
diabetes Street [ __ ] snails that kind
of racial sweat in a club like MC
Bonjour bro it's a ghetto oyster what I
want to know is how do we have Mexican
hot dogs brought because we don't
[ __ ] waste anything but in Mexico the
hot dogs are red what's up with that she
died right I don't even know what the
[ __ ] it is weed everything what the [ __ ]
could be in the hotdogs we eat this now
we let three pass it's a rolling 47 you
don't like people tacos I use it better
when I know and I know what it is nice
because I saw my aunt make oh no I saw
my I'm making the three pause that home
it was nasty brush rights it wasn't
there cleaning them and then you had to
clean them I seen some big old Munoz was
right there like at a Raiders game
they're barely clean them in the throw
him in there I
like my dad you stick me oh yeah my nice
to watch I'm like especially like on my
dad will hang around with a bunch of
people that were then Rick work on cars
and they're all hanging out at after
work we're fixing this truck at their
job and they and then somebody who later
it's make a carne asada and I'm looking
around everybody has dirty-ass hands you
can have carne asada
everybody has oil in their hands that
one person said have washed their hands
bro in the last 30 years and in a
show-up
Brewer just dropping it bro nobody's
like that over their hands bro they do
they waited for the grill to get really
hot right they scraped it with some
I'm a metal brush they just drop it bro
they put it onion and onions dudes they
used to lay our asphalt and they do the
guy grab his hand started like ripping
the [ __ ] go sit over there
everybody told us when you're little
there's like a party they killed a pig
are you for everybody oh yeah bro I
usually every time we would go to Mexico
they would do it like that yeah I was
there Mexico No oh they're in Mexico
Rose me bro yeah Rose me somebody's
backyard bro and they had like a bar
that's when Rose beam was like the
stakes are whole and it had goats and
pigs bro I mean my little brother would
play with these goats feeding them they
were chasing us and then our southern
brothers [ __ ] redneck guy and his
paisa or the ugliest cousins they don't
like they were cousin bro for the same
dad both ugly brother was a redneck guy
he look exactly like his cousin Mexican
guru and we were chasing us and we had
names for them and they walked up to it
behind us they just grabbed them and
slit their throats that's the best way
to do it
if you get them on their stress the meat
supposedly tastes bad but it's crazy if
you get them with what no they have to
be nice to crazy they don't know what
it's coming because if it's coming to
tell you
they were runny with her they were
running still with her heads cut off and
as a kid you're just like whatever we
would save the blood but a crying bro
[ __ ] I'm gonna tell you uh when you were
playing with the little goats when you
little kid
April no those little goats try to like
jump and RAM you w-well I saw this these
bite-size having a party and snapchat
it's against him your photo and they had
the little chip abroad he was too tied
up so I look a little rope to a gate and
everybody gave me four top row and they
were like tap it in here with a beer and
she ate at this other day in this new
year bro that cuz they've usually it's a
little go noise near no not a go like if
they just grabbed it and it's right
there in a little farm in the
slaughterhouse I think so once they're
like Park Falls I could fool Tuffy gee
you know you think they're gonna beat
your ass yeah I'm gonna be bad oh yeah
you don't need meat fool do you ah not
at all how long has it been to talk with
you ever
mm why'd you stop I have constipated for
like a week no [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah bro no
foreign animal right black man get up
bro follow me on instagram Felipe
Esparza comedian on Instagram follow me
on Twitter funny Felipe and also bad my
[ __ ] up Felipe Esparza YouTube page
is blowing up man yeah go check that out
virus bars on YouTube page I'll put a
video up I'm getting 15,000 views a day
the next level baby once so full
upcoming shows I'll be Raleigh North
Carolina this weekend February 7 to a 9
at the brand new rally improv that seats
five hundred people hopefully we'll have
more than a hundred
bystander California February 14 Fox
Theater for a show sold out we added a
second show nights at 10:30 until now
Fresno California
the next day February 15 at the Tower
Theater first
sold out we added a second shot for your
ass at 10:30 also on sale now Chicago
not the city Schaumburg the suburbs
February 21st or 23rd at the Chicago
Improv in Schaumburg Toppenish
Washington Yakima Pasco tri-city area
March 6 at legends casino find all my
shows dates and ticket links at flipper
WorldCom slashed or what stuff we got
you got that roof still going on you
know show coming up at uh well we got
the show that you just did and in
Spanish and the Ice House we got that on
a monthly basis and I'm doing a short in
Victorville yeah that's the bad shoulder
the hotel at the Holiday Inn right the
holiday at the Holiday Inn in
Victorville Victorville and nature well
that was nice brother crazy show dog it
was called before that cool people would
have hung on and dance or something it's
deep people show up there we love people
show the Sunday night to dock yeah bro
people show up they [ __ ] they get
drunk
anyway saying I like it's not too far
from LA you know how long have you had
that room at Victorville and where's it
at for people who live out there can
come to the next show what's the exit
it's uh I don't know 15 right up with a
flaw Maureen but it's right there
Holiday Inn right off of the 15 and
through my got it through my partner
Carlos Sarmiento which is called cars
auto body shop he's the one that he
produces show kids always did a Spanish
oh no that was her first show in Spanish
or you know Travis Travis uses the
smaller brothers Tabasco isn't tables
tables table show yeah yeah he doesn't
show at the other room yeah yeah yeah
but I like it I like it there we've done
shows in Lancaster we done shows in
Bakersfield in Porterville and because
of little small towns [ __ ] people
show up you're not to drink and they
like to laugh
you show up as a comedian it goes well
for you man cuz people are there to
laugh the radio party and tell a lot if
I can merchandise Peter hook up - huh
what's that - funny hook up yeah there's
nothing else to do bro you hook up and
party
I bet if you're a person let you do
drugs that's a big that's a good cake
for you huh that party a little cool
they're trying to [ __ ] you show me a bag
like what else you gonna do I did I show
it like a couple of weeks ago to Sirius
California or seriesis they used to call
me yes that's where many more than
others from all right
that is Coketown you would say how to
the [ __ ] yeah bro pong ball bro never
say this California is right next to the
hub where all that [ __ ] shows up but
that's to California uh-huh yeah they
like to party hard they like to party in
the club that we play bro it was a bar
it was called the rusty nail it was
[ __ ] the only Club around within five
miles so there is no competition shout
out to whoever right now whoa but uh
it's crazy stealing places like that
like steadies California Visalia
California little west town like that
mm-hmm
these fools find out you're from Los
Angeles they want to top you bro I know
you we're gonna party like you're in our
late oh yeah I'll bring her too much
drugs yeah yeah these guys told us that
me Rodrigo and Edward someone he said
we're gonna party with you they're like
it's all a these [ __ ] showed up
was two pounds of stress blogs Rousseau
you don't stand there was a set of
pillows really like like poor bird peek
inside and then the police showed up
that's well you know it's funny how you
say about that like we go to a small
towns people they just live in LA want
to talk to you about LA I'm an uber
[ __ ] back I used to live on this
you're their lead dog you know they're
excited to talk about LA they're handing
me ziplock so sandwiches bags [ __ ]
filled with cocaine here go to the
bathroom Pamela head
no mom you saw your nose really see
those two where is at the wanna bridge
Astana stand-up comedy and when did you
get that George Lopez wristband bro and
where'd you get us hair your arms this
is my George Lopez this is YPG Peter oh
nice oh really
yeah you should get these jolly rakia
bro bikes that's [ __ ] cool dude
that's for the he's gonna warrior
princess Murtagh I bought a bunch of a
bunch of leather and I you know got the
equipment but a [ __ ] and went on
YouTube they're willingly oh yeah could
you guys see it Wow I'm sorry comedy
here in LA or in Portland I'm sorry
where do you short of stand-up comedy
yet I started I actually can't live oh
yeah he was an actor dude like
Shakespearean theatre
yeah I was an ass in Oregon doing
Shakespeare you could tell by the way
you do doing theater [ __ ] smoking
balls reading to be or not to be right
and some Jewish lady [ __ ] City come
on you wanna go to LA and I was like nah
man I'm [ __ ] cool here goes come on
go to LA you can be every every bad guy
you know they're gonna want you they're
gonna cast you in middle I will go come
in so I'm like all right [ __ ] it let's
go to LA then came to LA bro and I went
from to be or not to be or is this a
dagger which I see before me you know
single lines in [ __ ] like that
representing my people and then I come
to LA know the scripts I got were like a
little penguin you want to buy a bag
we're all so I got all depressed I
[ __ ] went into it this big depression
I quit acting and then [ __ ] everybody
said bro you [ __ ] talk about this
[ __ ] talk about the [ __ ] that happened
and that's all I've gotten to stand-up
comedy and how long you been doing it
for now sento comedy but not now he was
no Hamlet bro a little hamlet yeah not
to be you know some bro or dick back
Macbeth in Latinas culturally prevalence
got the famous monologue that we all
like heroes you're a dagger 1 you know
what it was when Lady Macbeth tells them
you gotta kill the [ __ ] king man is
having it so you can become King and
he's walking around all [ __ ] up and he
sees these daggers uh-huh
you know he imagines these daggers and
that's the famous line when he goes is
this a dagger which I see before me the
handle toward my hand come let me clutch
thee
I feel V not yet I see thee still nobody
remember that life but they're gonna
remember this one bro
hey what happened to Pie Face I didn't
like it you know but it had to be done
they don't remember they don't remember
a dagger before me but they remember
don't look at me a little puppet that's
our family homey that's John ChaCha he's
a great actor be mesmerising dog yeah
but they think use of George George like
Paul Rodriguez told me that he saw John
Turturro kill it in Shakespeare in the
Park in the in end of Central Park New
York and now he's but he's in a movie
called The Big Lebowski yeah sorry boy
let me tell you something they say well
that's big s curse Peter doesn't pay bro
theaters for the Arts yeah if you want
to make a living in theater you gotta
sing and dance you know what the best
pick-up line is for a young actress
what's that you know what we just get
married man and open her own theater the
best pick-up line is I'm a producer me
how I can cast yeah and you just get lay
like a [ __ ]
but everyone for me but
comprado Al Kooper Murray Gavin yeah
yeah that's how easy how does pick-up
line that fool the street from from a
compadre broads it or really the same
house with Joey and all those guys
that's a dope ass party let me just take
a little shower put in sandals and
welcome to the bar is may be allowed
tourists white chicks and he'd be like
yeah I'm a producer that apartment on
the street that's a way to pick up
chicks you live by yeah I do this them
stardom and they'll [ __ ] but now it's
harder cuz they can look you up you know
online like oh man but not everybody
looks you up in your sperm yeah look at
that bathroom casting I'm only on imbd
but that's smooth smooth John cause out
there if I can dude and they just
[ __ ] get laid a lot of women have
been duped yeah well there's there's
people that was Suthers so to be a taco
shop bro but the only one that they want
ever done a resume right like oh yeah
what gigs they want to be famous
yeah they want to build up that imbd
right well dude would you suck a dick
for if I can start them
dude circulate a little twink I don't
know I think killing Jenner there's a
conspiracy theory that if you want to
make it in Hollywood if you want to make
it big you want to become a top and like
an a-list actress Scientology you got
some thick I don't believe it I don't I
heard you don't believe that gotta be
clean even so no dig bro I think that's
why there's only one cleaning
I think so brother people say all Will
Smith is gay it's a power trip roach I
think even cleanest what broke up
producer just died that make a producer
with with the robber or with the glasses
and the [ __ ] pulled face or that for
the player bro Robert something the kid
takes in the field I think there's some
truth to that bro just so producer could
walk around going yeah clean ease would
I [ __ ] them
I think they surprised to pay bro you
think you get those parties look at look
at that little uh I think like exactly
they [ __ ] children you don't think
they'll [ __ ] adults I don't know man I
honestly don't know like if they want to
do they're investing thousands and
thousands of dollars in you millions bro
right Malins they do you think they're
not gonna want anything back in return
just the [ __ ] money
but it'll be like dude I built this fool
now like any [ __ ] it's a power trip
roll I don't know
honest you don't think so dude that's
probably maybe I'm naive though old
Hollywood that's not like the internet
cuz you not to do [ __ ] like that right I
mean when you got a producer Robert
Evans Robert Evans do that's his name
you did a documentary called the kid
stays in the picture because the stories
of the Robert every was a young actor
very handsome and he chose to do a film
and they made him the lead but he
couldn't act for [ __ ] and he was
complaining that they were gonna [ __ ]
leave right if he stays he's in a movie
and I [ __ ] for two so the movie she
came to a film set and told all the
actors the kid stays in the picture
mm-hmm and then write the Robert ever
said [ __ ] actor I want to be that guy
and then we came a big [ __ ] like man
he's like one of the first mega predator
he's to party bro with Don Simpson bro
from same season buh-buh-buh Kaymer boat
crimer
you know what's badass the new bad boys
movie has [ __ ] Don Simpsons name on
it tight dogs I was like that was the
best part of the movie for me dude
that's there's a book Don Simpson was
one of the
he was a producer with Simpsons and Buck
Bruckheimer bad boy that was like one of
the Beverly Hills Cop gun he were the
one that came up with idea of putting a
black guy and a white guy together in
action films
oh I'm putting a salt rack in a movie no
weapon homie another 48 hours right Wow
we can't go you think definitely but you
think people give up that ass again I
think if women do Don Simpson said this
in his book yeah nineteen-year-old for
us her name was her name
I want to say meg Ryan should make it to
his room bro ya know that we should
married to UM Toria Banderas my god Ryan
no 20 years old it was right you know
what she wanted be in films right Rock
Hudson before he died you know ruckus
yeah yeah Specter yeah no Hudson when
they told him hey bro can you before he
was dying now that you have AIDS and
you're dying you don't give a [ __ ] about
going on can you give us some names
about who's the gay in Hollywood and he
obviously he declined he said no I'm not
gonna give you names but I'll tell you
this in the Hollywood world there are
more gay people than not so if that's
being a everybody never thought he was
gay right till he came up with a zine
yeah everybody yeah he was the [ __ ]
he was exactly and he said there's more
gay people in Hollywood than not I can
never picture like John Wayne sucking a
dick
Oh Dirty Harry either pitiless
I don't think I don't think so though
maybe that's why so pissed these days
huh together Mike dollar commercial I
got robbed right
I got Rockford three years he didn't rob
that little bottle I got I got it all
back at then it was a dual man I told
you it was like a lady Mexican lady and
her ex-husband some black guy and they
had kids together so they ran that door
that they ran the company together and
wanted me how much money they like
[ __ ] they dipped they bounced and
then [ __ ] when I called the office is
really only went out of business so yeah
crazy dude but you got with another
talent agency they gave me no no no no
this is to a City California I I fired
it - oh really yeah and then after I got
through with aqua yeah okay and they
drop Ari so hopefully my I get more
auditions steps up additions yeah those
are meet auditions yeah what's up fool
thank you everybody who showed up to the
observatory theater in Santa Ana
California I'll spawn man did our
English special on Tuesday two shows and
then we did the Spanish special fully
edited down the special and then my
another adding it down right and they
edit it down to an hour and 15 minutes
and they said it was too long so now
they're gonna take one of the 50 minutes
out but bonus right there bro boy there
were an hour both of them for 14 hour
yeah that's bonus wage right there bro
well I'm already working on my new stuff
bro how excited bro yeah so easy is that
for another special dude yeah I got some
jokes right have that never said so
we'll see oh yeah that's fine are you
ready for your second special that's
what it is what's up fool so he started
stand-up comedy where I started in LA in
LA uh-huh that the haha cafe I remember
paying five bucks to go through the open
mic they got me for that right I did it
a couple of times started hanging around
at the Comedy Store and then I felt well
[ __ ] yeah but that's not my place to go
you know and then I discovered what they
call it the Latino common room yeah the
burrito circus the burrito the Eastside
whole circuit you know doing the Pico
Rivera fundraisers and [ __ ] like that
notice the bastard Pitino tour that's
[ __ ] show me yeah let me tell you
those [ __ ] shows man they really I
went from doing three minutes sets to
doing [ __ ] 20 minutes says yeah
granted it was on the front of Chicanos
all the [ __ ] time so they get to get
a little those are the only people that
end up point you shows anyways oh yeah
the people gonna buy tickets man
yeah but it can hurry it hinder you man
it really can cuz you get used to plane
to the same kind of audience yours
killing yeah exactly and but then you
walk out of that you go into a black
room he about to repeat the same joke
about to slow it down
broke ass Jordan zone that's that was
the catch man and for a long time it was
I didn't want to leave the Latino
circuit because I was comfortable there
yeah but then you know you start you
start booking little towns like in
Palmdale you when you go I did a couple
Tribble runs you know what to Oregon you
know entertaining mags ammeter Walla
Walla yeah bro and then you just can't
you can't talk about a theaters of North
in [ __ ] Eddie Montana bro cap we got
change of row right Tiger I can't cuz I
die I my joke is they did tell that I
you know I've I have married to a white
girl and she lost [ __ ] to los Tigres
of North a you know so that [ __ ] doesn't
really change your bro you guys said
America white [ __ ] you like [ __ ] you to
of narco narco music narco corridos
narco music people that you bought
everyone dark music is it like kind of
like hip-hop music but instead of even
in Montana instead of guns you hear
sirens broadly and like hip hop instead
of gun shows you hear
you better play with it bro you gotta
work it ya know doing Spanish that
really helped that because when you get
stuck in English man you just [ __ ]
started doing the Spanish and they said
that they would she said you get new
ideas because as you found out you just
can't you just can't translate your
shows they don't know you can't transfer
you got to start thinking in Spanish you
guys are doing actual jokes exactly it's
like you've seen the other half of your
brain bro sorry reading a book is
banish'd now inaudible okay lies torreón
Mexico capital or this March are limp a
dilettante no she still on ah in a real
life bro like you know I've been
listening to the Spanish version of the
history of Mexico the my initiate [ __ ]
bro people lie to you bro [ __ ] now
much assume over pretty much hit liberal
to old people I'm [ __ ] them up every
day dawg
then he said no [ __ ] choice Brolin
we're gonna go with you white people
that [ __ ] wanna kill you together
that [ __ ] rape your mom and kill your
little sister it's a [ __ ] effort on
you like he was a coach or six point
five million people bro but but you just
crazy bro crazy with power well think
about Mexican history though they give
you both sides of right hand left it's
not like here they just keep it like
what so they gave me the story of what
what happened and then like the what the
Spaniard wrote wow that's cool yeah they
were given the Native American recipe
Mexico's that the the the temple were
the capital of [ __ ] the the Aztec
warrior the astok ruins a main one
Empire Tennessee it wasn't beautiful
according to Cortes words like he did it
what he did not want to destroy it first
this built on water
it was beautiful bro that's why Mexico
City we think it was a series of little
islands
moats yeah because this were like the
rich people had their own place to live
up to in that area but his with a
[ __ ] Palace Palace bro ya know they
have floating gardens and [ __ ] and they
did it for strategic purposes the full
word eat their their friends bro
they're gonna get power Wow after you
got shot
they'll eat your brother heart like in
China right well they believe come on
we're all we're all little religious
religions have us all a little ignorant
believing in [ __ ] you know they
believe in their own [ __ ] like we
believe in our own [ __ ] but they do
believe some they believe the sacrifices
and and they they use of sacrifice I've
read like every dog yeah bro everyday to
appease the gods if they wanted rain
let's kill 50 [ __ ] where's our
enemy daddy
exactly exactly well I mean you just go
to this little girl here in the US when
everybody said there's nothing but
Indian tribes they're all fighting and
[ __ ] yeah you know isn't it all [ __ ]
everybody sit here just making bow and
arrows and making pottery dawg no not at
all bro we're all tea warrior culture
brain exactly the Native Americans up
here used to [ __ ] fight each other
for territory and for food for the
[ __ ] you know basic necessities of
life in that time you had what like
pre-columbian you have the assets you
have the minds of the Incas yeah make us
it the Mohicans into our watts this is
cool part that didn't know about the
Aztecs they were doing the trades
because they didn't just give him the
gold first they give him like they stay
there for about a bag of of 20 dozen
tamales bro so for they could eat
maybe with spiders I guess I don't know
and then they send them a bunch of that
out the hardcore liquor they drink cool
cool cool cake and hot chocolate right
but with him I went to the they got the
gold bro they sell a gold of course I
can what can i buzzes name buzzer what a
stupid bro
he told us every one of your hats one of
those [ __ ] uh the Spaniard hat and
the foot said yeah boy you send it back
full of gold okay they said [ __ ] that
they never sent back that hat where they
kept it and it went back to their old
ruin their old writings and they [ __ ]
found that that hat looked at the Hat
that showed up in 1492 somewhere else
it's a bottle now that was a whole
mirrored thing with envy not
a horse having armor will the [ __ ]
gods coming back bro that's right Tim
bubble cut him with what the fire
redhead but I mean there's a lot of
[ __ ] factors involved whether played
a big ol fat fact whether we don't even
know they said that they were the mind
that the last thing where I put two if
the timer never showed up
they were pretty kill each other off
anyways there would have been something
like it was like our land or like acres
and acres of rotting bodies already
Orlando somebody and invariably just
beast roaring bird they would have
uprisings to dog but if somebody was
gonna win out of those three ones like
the Incas in the Mayans and ask
something would happen later yeah yeah I
mean they say but I mean obviously with
human nature ethos a better way for
after he died
you thought that um they were gonna stop
fighting but [ __ ] no man o'war really
started but quantum oak and a bunch of
but they work yeah I was looking up
growth it was like look it up in Spanish
no child look for look up on Google no
chair the three-state no chair the
triste night of of sadness and that's
when I don't you Trish Tessa this test
I'm gonna coach and I come in are
hardcore [ __ ] [ __ ] up and by that
they were almost funny they have those
value dancing naked for there was a
whole thousands of people laugh to leave
and the regroup and them opposite [ __ ]
that you know food getting off the
subject here back to comedy what's up
Peter
anyway comedy in Spanish but though how
long you been doing that you for I've
been do comedy Spanish for about half of
what I've been doing it in English force
what's gonna be fun yeah yeah bro and
it's been good man it's been good it's
it's a little it's a more personal since
Spanish was my first language
you too yeah you know because you know
when you when you start doing comedy in
English you stick to like the classes
that I went to and you stick to like
making jokes in class no I never I know
I've never been to East LA you know you
start with just jokes jokey jokey
[ __ ] - you know I you know I'm you
[ __ ] you know just the you make the
observation and then you [ __ ] flip it
around and stuff like that and then in
Spanish is more like a confession oh
yeah in Spanish podcast but exactly you
start talking about that's when I stuck
it in Posada me mom are they by then
it's miss is more of a personal approach
to comedy so I really really dug that
[ __ ] especially having the ability to
doing in Spanish and in English and then
you mix the two and I think it enhances
the comedy very much so I'm sure you
found out yeah brah
my next my next shows it'll be all crowd
works bro
I might have I'm gonna have an Arab guy
sitting in the front a cholo a white guy
and then we'll just go with that bro
whatever my wicked funny bro like I'm
gonna - what are your terrorists they
might have that guy stand up holding a
bazooka funny bro I feel like I feel
like a meanie doing crowd work like it
sounds something new but it's a gimmick
brand it's like it's all it's a there's
a way to do it right and a way to be
wrong and if you're a white guy doing
crowd work it's always gonna be funny
because you're white yeah and you can
make fun of stereotype like keeping a
white or black guy Oh black guys real
fast he puts a cholo all my skin here
right whatever take a joke and then you
pick an Arab guy Oh Palestine you know
jokes about that so it's easy you know
I'm pretty sure some of these crowd work
comics are planting these people inside
bro
sometimes it looks too obvious what do
you do for a living right yeah you mean
like a play by Jeff Garcia which is one
of the best right I mean one of the best
that was probably the guy that he that's
what he did hey I'm not you know I don't
like the guy but I pretty sure his crowd
work compared to what's out there come
on man I seen this guy killing one time
we're doing the same bid in ten
different shows yeah the only time I
seen him were it didn't work that one
night fourth fourth to be that was it
because it was far away from the stage
but other than that
homeboy used to thrive on that [ __ ] yeah
also like got what's it mean that
Canadian community he's good
Ian back back that story about that fool
real quick and I've said it before he
was doing a warm-ups at K locals one
time and there was a comedian in the
front row he's all hey man so what do
you do for a living I'm a comedian man
where do you work at I work at the Laugh
Factory man never heard of it like but
it's funny what you said like right
right now crowd works is a big popular
crowd work is good because right now
people are posting it up you're fast the
material the Beast but dude this [ __ ]
black comics Oh
that'll destroy any white car Mike who's
doing crowd work right I just gotta give
a little plug real quick Duke with that
show that you did in Texas with all
those fools dude somebody I never
[ __ ] you about that's funny as [ __ ]
dog Rudy rush dog and I'm sure he was
barely even started that night with a
little ten minutes yeah baby get up this
crowd word oh yeah I'm surprised
departed because people get offended so
easily nowadays Quadro a white car be
doing it bro be racist or Latino how
many kids do you have
ha ha ha oh you're Latino how was your
baby at pregnant black he probably
tripped over his dick huh I may use that
thank you that's your boyfriend all
right yeah but you can't do it somewhere
else
Hey
yeah that's what that's alright but
unless it's hot right now man but it
ain't new hmm and it's gonna die out
people gonna figure it out yeah yeah
people are good no matter what bro I
don't think people want to see or gonna
give you a money to do a whole Netflix
special just a crowd work exactly no you
gotta have material man and this crowd
work and a squad work it's something you
cannot film and have people show up and
call it right make it right and to be
spontaneous bro that's especially when
you're playing I mean when you playing
clubs you can get away with it but if
when you play yeah my crowd work is so
funny that I cannot go back to my
regular set which is why I do crowd
worry about that so true it's hard
enough tired of that if I do crowd work
it's gonna be funnier than everything I
written already right and I cannot
follow that because now that would be
like oh that's that's rehearsed man you
know as we're gonna be thinking you know
the people yeah Peter Peter has to hit
the street all right Peter Peter bad
with your next show it's gonna be was
like next year it's gonna be Austin abhi
at the Harbor Inn it's gonna be February
February 13th I'm gonna be headlining
it's gonna be fun so if you're in the
Ventura area please look it up or you
can go to my website wwlp.com podcasts
yes and also please listen to our
podcast and espanol thank you so much
con Martin Moreno Cleon note they are
soo stay spot you can listen to iTunes
and we're also on YouTube
so please look us up and notice who says
podcasts go with Martin Moreno with your
social media handle my social media you
can find me for the same name pinche
Peter P I and th IPG Peter at Facebook
PG Peter at Twitter pinche Peter at
instagram @ PG Peter Eliza on you too so
you've been my hero for a long time it
means a lot how old are you given the
time so thank you so much and thank you
for opening doors for us in the Spanish
realm oh yeah
so no they're double [ __ ] crummy
little